you see that Super Bowl game yesterday
when an exciting game B New England
Patriots were beaten by the Philadelphia
Eagles 41 to 33 yeah yeah Eagles fans
started fires and they punched police
horses then they sat down to watch the
Super Bowl
that's how typical what's wrong with the
Eagles fan warmup yeah time for the
Super Bowl
they cook they call that tailgating yeah
they were taking down street lamps and
carrying them around carrying the wrong
reason carrying around like like
lampposts I was like that's work yeah
there are people that carry heavy things
for a living yeah they're like let's
celebrate let's build an off-ramp hey
forget it forget it we're not talking
anymore camera I hate that camera this
is crazy speaking of Eagle fans during
Super Bowl celebrations in Philadelphia
yesterday an Eagles fan got so carried
away he ate horse poop right off the
street now in his defense the man
thought it was dog poop so kind of my
some of these local commercials are
causing controversy a lot of people are
mad about a Ram truck ad that used the
words of dr. Martin Luther King jr. yeah
yeah people were particularly suspicious
of the part where dr. King says civil
rights are RAM tastic
[Applause]
you